what's happening [ __ ] uncle Joey
here getting ready for my little [ __ ]
poop salute show since I'm gonna hotel
room I don't like smoking we cuz they
call forget 9-1-1 so I got my Eureka
[ __ ] vapor pen this is the
strongest [ __ ] out there my Eureka boys
are in Colorado wait for me this
[ __ ] week when I show up there
on [ __ ] Thursday to the Comedy Works
vapors reefers edibles Denver get ready
a [ __ ] Rock you understand me but
that's next week tonight here with the
[ __ ] Cherokee tribe Oklahoma making
it happen
mmm good to the last drop [ __ ] but
you know what time it is right look at
this I brought these [ __ ] stars in
debt these are the 125 so I gotta eat
like 22 you don't saying what are you
gonna do I love these [ __ ] things you
understand me and you know what if you
live in LA now the stars are available
on [ __ ] LA speed weed my
Mangino making it happen so if you're in
LA tonight
don't be bored don't worry about nothing
call a speed wheat and they'll deliver
the stars a debt right to your [ __ ]
door who's better than you huh psychic
on it they deliver right to your
[ __ ] door anyway we're here
have a nice dinner with Steve Simone I
smoked the number out there now I'm in
here with you [ __ ] checking up on
you when you know I didn't forget about
you and just been hanging out with the
Indians you see I'm saying she's not
[ __ ] Indian like that I don't [ __ ]
around jack I've been with the Indians
just day one they run this [ __ ] you just
don't know that
I love eating these stars at that I'm
gonna open up with like 900 milligrams
just to take it easy I'm going on that
stage tonight like a [ __ ] savage
understand me I'm done October 15th
Rosemont I'm in training you kick me or
what
you know how the Catholic Church gives
you [ __ ] the body of Christ
that's the Church of what's happening
now that's the body of [ __ ] Christ
right there hope you guys are having a
great night I hope you got some great
plans I hope you stay safe hmm I hope
you tuned up and that said [ __ ]
we will do one at least tomorrow from my
balcony in Los Angeles but I'll check
them with you [ __ ] later you know
I'm saying stars seven days a week we're
in [ __ ] training Lisa no I mean blue
apron and that's it my friend like I
said [ __ ] Eureka is the best I switch
them bolt I go from a [ __ ] sativa -
when did I check this [ __ ] out just like
that's insane these guys [ __ ] I've
been with you Rico for a few years now
oh [ __ ] I forgot to stop you know don't
listen if you're gonna run with me
during the week you gotta run deep but
if you're gonna run with me on a
Saturday night you better back the
[ __ ] lunch jack
the power of Christ compels you
I have a great time I'll see you
[ __ ] tomorrow Monday podcast
Wednesday podcast Tuesday night
[ __ ] uh the black court saloon
up on whatever Boulevard was seen a
Boulevard 55 oh seven nine o'clock with
the Agostino and then Thursday Friday
Saturday an economy worse in dental
[ __ ] I love you guys stay black
don't forget